Space,
the final frontier…
Our technology is catching up to Star Trek…
So can we now
fly the Enterprise?
“Shall we begin?”
No! Today the Enterprise couldn’t do half
what the
filmmakers imagined.
We have too many rules.
Would you ride your bike without a helmet?
We’ll get him too
Buckle up day and night
or you will get caught.
By contrast,
the Enterprise didn’t even have seat belts.
We’re at the point
where the Enterprise wouldn’t get off the ground.
Of course it would.
I would be there.
William Shatner now mocks me
for calling for less government.
And that’s a wonderful principle to have.
Government, stay out of our lives.
And yet,
how do you have too many safety rules?
You don’t know that that wall isn’t going to fall in,
and if it fell in, and then
you said,
”Why didn’t you make a rule?”
It’s good there are rules about
cigarette smoking
It’s bad for you,
but it could be worse for me
if I’m breathing in second-hand smoke,
even on your clothes.
That’s worth a regulation.
And they regulate it, they tax it,
but they don’t ban it.
Well, because
people want to smoke.
Yes!
And free people want to do all kinds of risky things!
We ought to be allowed to.
Tomato soup
Remember that food producing machine
on the Enterprise?
There are 14 varieties of tomato soup available
from this replicator
You could get whatever you wanted.
In real life, today’s food police would
limit your choices.
I would like a large Cola.
Your choice is unavailable.
Foie Gras.
And when the crew had to go,
regulators would mandate many choices.
Does this really need to be a thing?
And the TSA would make it hard to board.
No phasers,
no tricorders,
if I catch you with the tricorder
you will not make this transport
Mr. Scott,
ready to beam up
Beam up?
The transportation department would say
“that’s too dangerous!”
I watch government regulate
this and that
and this.
Star Trek would have…
Well aren’t they trying to do good?
Aren’t they trying?
Aren’t these little men,
who’ve never been on a horse,
trying to do good
by limiting
your broken bones
Your argument
of no regulations
doesn’t hold water.
I didn’t say “no regulations”
Well then, where do you draw the line?
Many, many fewer.
I want to be able to drink raw milk
if I’m stupid enough to try it.
Well, but nobody should be drinking milk.
No other species
drinks another species’ milk.
If you do it, you’re going to kill yourself.
All kinds of terrible things, like flatulence,
will happen to you.
“Darkness
is
coming”
Darkness has come.
because today even Captain Kirk doesn’t
want to explore space
We can’t live on Mars, a)
and b)
to get three people to Mars
is monumental in cost,
so you’re not going to populate Mars,
you’re going to send some people to die, or get out
of there as quickly as possible.
It's going to be like the moon.
Oh come on,
private space travel is taking over.
NASA no longer insists on government doing it all.
We could be entering a wonderful new era of
libertarian exploration…
We libertarians would do it differently.
We’ll boldly go where no one’s gone before,
discover new species,
and…
leave them alone.
Space,
the final frontier.
Our continuing mission
to seek out new life
and new civilizations
and leave them alone.
To trade with them
if they want
but to mostly
leave them
alone.